your daughter is almost 16 what she like
is that I we have a 3 5 13 and 18 year
old so I mean after you lost me after
the second one yeah yeah yeah a teenager
that can be trying oh my god just keep
us in your prayers my daughter she it's
hard to watch herself she's like
watching now that she's older it's like
watching myself it's scary but what I'm
so grateful to God for is that I'm a
woman and I can teach her how to be a
woman I was a single mom which I did not
expect to be I didn't have her until I
was 35 years old so I had already had
career first and then kind of you know
just you know got into motherhood and I
think it's been the most gratifying and
amazing and just rocky road that I've
ever taken in my life but she's that one
person that I would die without in the
blink of an eye for yeah so it's it's
motherhood first and then everything
else yeah there's so much there's so
much love but yes sometimes I'm like you
got love you but I don't like you right
now so for your safety you should leave
my presence that's because they didn't
know us before we were mine I can tell
who might be meeting this person real
slow
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when I give it up to mothers god bless
you I think it's wonderful loving them I
never thought I'd be one my mom is still
like oh my god you have children and a
husband you got away this is my favorite
thing I've ever heard with parenting
you've got away with your daughter to
kind of punish her and it deals with a
cell phone almost definitely we live in
the day and age where you know
everything we all have cell phones it's
like you know we are attached to our
devices and you know I tried taking the
cell phone away from her which you know
it wasn't really advantageous for me
because she takes over sometimes and we
need the cell phone so okay I'm gonna
get you a flip phone I got and now
everything goes through my phone you
know so I know how to shut her down when
I need to there's a way of punishing
someone without you know not having
contact with them we could still have
contact but I had to give her a flip
phone because but I love that you
control I when she's with her friends
and she pulls out her Ferris Bueller
[Laughter]
[Applause]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going